nach dem brutalen Terroranschlag der
Hamas am 7 oktober stehen sowohl Israel
als auch Gaza wieder im Rampenlicht der
internationalen Medien dabei konnten wir
Meinungen Kritik und Anschuldigung aller
Art hören von so einflussreichen
Politikern wie Biden Scholz und macron
die die israelische Regierung
unterstützen bis hin zu aufmerschen auf
den Straßen Europas Z Gunsten der Hamas
und wie gewohnt tauchen all die üblichen
Verdächtigen auf der Bildfläche auf um
den Staat Israel für seine militärische
Reaktion auf die Anschläge scharf zu
kritisieren darunter auch viele
internationale Organisationen natürlich
gibt es bei einem so kontroversen Thema
Meinungen aller Art und etwas für jeden
Geschmack allerdings konzentrieren wir
uns in diesem Video auf den
wohlhärtesten Vorwurf der in den letzten
Wochen gegen den Staat Israel erhoben
wurde Israels Apartheit gegen
Palästinenser eine grausames
Herrschaftssystem und ein Verbrechen
gegen die Menschlichkeit Amnesty
International laut verschiedener
Menschenrechts Organisationen wie
Amnesty International grenzt Israel das
sogenannte palästinensische Volk seit
Jahren aus und diskriminiert es mit
einem System der
[Musik]
Apartheit genauer gesagt sind die Araber
in zwei verschiedenen Gebieten isoliert
auf der einen Seite haben wir den
Gazastreifen in dem zurzeit mehr als 2
Millionen Menschen eingesperrt sind und
auf der anderen Seite das Westjordanland
wo 3 Millionen Menschen leben das
Problem mit dem letztgenannten Gebiet
ist allerdings dass das Westjordanland
keine einheitlicher herum ist sondern
die arabber in dieser Region isoliert in
kleinen Städten und Dörfern leben die
von israelisch kontrollierten Gebiet
umgeben sind so heißt es z.B dass wenn
ein Araber im Westjordanland wenn er von
einer Stadt in eine andere fahren möchte
beispielsweise von Betlehem nach Hebron
er israelisch kontrollierte Gebiete
durchqueren muss und dass die Israelis
dann angeblich die Straßen blockieren
würden damit die Araber nicht heraus
können außerdem gibt es große bis zu 7 m
hohe Betonmauern mit militärischen
Wachposten die den Arabern theoretisch
die Flucht aus ihrem Wohnort verwehren
aus diesem Grund haben viele
Organisationen berichtet dass die Araber
wie in Käfigen leben würden bewacht und
ständig vom Staat Israel kontrolliert
gleichzeitig könnten sich Israelis aber
frei bewegen wo immer Sie wollen und
genössen volle Rechte die Sprache ist
von Bürgern erster Klasse den Juden und
Bürgern zweiter Klasse den Arabern und
das nicht nur in Bezug auf die
Bewegungsfreiheit viele Organisationen
behaupten dass die Araber im
Westjordanland und im Gazastreifen kein
Wahlrecht kein Recht auf
Staatsbürgerschaft oder wohnsitzwahl
hätten vor Militärgerichte gestellt
würden und für Sie andere Gesetze gelten
würden als für Israelis es gebe quasi
zwei Rechtssysteme eines für Juden und
eines für Araber aber die Beschwerden
und Anschuldigungen meine Lieben
Zuschauer hören damit nicht
auf bisher haben wir über Araber
gesprochen die im gazaastifen und in
Westjordanland leben aber keine
israelischen Staatsbürger sind es stellt
sich allerdings heraus dass es in Israel
selbst auch viele Muslime arabische
Herkunft gibt die in diesem Fall die
israelische Staatsbürgerschaft haben wir
sprechen hier von etwa 2 Millionen
Menschen gut 20% der Israel ischen
Bevölkerung theoretisch sollten diese in
Israel lebenden Muslime also vollwertige
Bürger Israels sein oder doch auch hier
weißen internationale Organisation
darauf hin dass es eine enorme
Diskriminierung von Muslimen in Israel
gebe sie argumentieren dass die
muslimische Bevölkerung in Ghettos
aufgeteilt sei dass Kinder gezwungen
würden ausschließlich muslimische
Schulen zu besuchen dass Menschen in den
nationalen Ausweisdokumenten nach ihrer
Religion gekennzeichnet würden und dass
sie systematisch diskriminiert würden um
ihre Bevölkerung zu dezimieren und ich
denke ihr wisst inzwischen worauf all
diese Argumente hinauslaufen all diese
Anschuldigungen gegen Israel sollen uns
an das apartheitsregime in Südafrika
erinnern mehr noch einige
propalästinensische aktivisten sprechen
gar von Genozid wir erinnern uns in
Südafrika wurde die schwarze Bevölkerung
ähnlich diskriminiert und ausgegrenzt
sie wurden in kleinen Gebieten den
sogenannten Townships eingepfercht aus
denen sie nicht heraus durften wie ihr
sehen könnt ineln auch diese Gebiete in
gewisser Weise denen die wir im
Westjordanland gesehen haben die die
schwarze Bevölkerung hatte kein
Wahlrecht das für sie geltende
Rechtssystem unterschiedt sich von dem
der weißen sie durften nicht am
politischen Leben teilnehmen und hatten
auch nicht die gleichen Bürgerrechte es
handelt sich um eine der jüngsten
Episoden von institutionalisiertenem
Rassismus in der Geschichte vielleicht
ist das der Grund warum viele
Organisationen und Aktivisten sie heute
mit Israel und den autonomen arabischen
Gebieten vergleichen es handelt sich um
eine äußerst schwerwiegende
Anschuldigung die von vielen Menschen
auf der ganzen Welt sehr ernst genommen
wird selbst von vielen Menschen die sich
sonst nicht sonderlich um die
Menschenrechte von Arabern oder Muslimen
Scheren sei es in Syrien dem Sudan dem
Iran oder China im Falle Israel sind
jedoch alle Maßstäbe vollkommen verrückt
und deswegen wollen wir in diesem Video
tiefer in die Materie einsteigen um die
folgenden Fragen zu beantworten was ist
dran an den apartheitsvorwürfen die
gegen Israel erhoben werden welche
Gemeinsamkeiten und Unterschiede gibt es
mit dem südafrikanischen Regime warum
verhält sich Israel so gegenüber den
Arabern bevor wir jedoch richtig
loslegen wollen wir euch mal einen
kleinen Einblick in unseren
Redaktionsalltag gewähren also
aufgepasst wie ihr vielleicht wisst gibt
es visualpolitik in verschiedenen
Sprachen auch z.B auf Spanisch da die
Themen für jedes Video immer von
mehreren Autoren erarbeitet werden muss
ich mich schon des öfteren mit meinem
spanischen Kollegen Oskar abstimmen und
das sieht dann so aus
osar
ja
[Musik]
a PA enroll es que
sabesaballo ah con
reaces recupar
la bacal pasta loses
[Musik]
Don okay so geht das nicht weiter ich
muss endlich ordentlich Spanisch lernen
nicht nur wegen der Arbeit sondern auch
für den Urlaub in diesem wunderschönen
Land was aber ist der beste Weg gerade
für jemanden wie mich der eigentlich
keine Zeit dazu hat und auch lernen muss
ganz normal umgangssprachlich mit
ungeduldigen schnellsprecherern die
Oscar umzugehen nun die Antwort ist klar
Bubble denn mit der Bubble App kann ich
mir meine eigenen Lernziele festlegen
und den Unterricht nach Belieben
gestalten du glaubst mir nicht dann
probi es aus bereits mit 3 bis 5 Minuten
täglich erreichst du deutliche
Fortschritte denn der Fokus von Bubble
liegt auf dem Erlernen von
gesprächsfähigkeiten die du direkt im
realen Leben anwenden kannst die
Lektionen wurden entsprechend von
hochprofessionell Sprachlehrern
entwickelt vor allem bietet Bubble auch
14 Sprachen und ein ganzes Ökosystem mit
vielen verschiedenen lernansätzen Bubble
ist nicht nur einfach eine App Bubbel
das sind Podcasts Zeitschriftenartikel
Spiel und Abertausende von regelmäßig
aktualisierten Inhalten die von echten
Sprachexperten und echten
Muttersprachlern verfasst wurden und
wenn du Bubble über den Link in der
Videobeschreibung abonnierst erhältst du
auch noch bis zu 70% Rabatt und außerdem
als visualpolit Community Bonus zwei
kostenlose live onlinekse oben drauf
natürlich kannst du das alles dank Geld
zurückgarantie ausgbig testen bevor du
dich entscheidest also worauf wartest du
noch schau dir Babel über den Link unter
diesem Video an und vielleicht wirst du
auch bald schon sogar Oscar in unseren
spanischen Videos verstehen können so
und nun ab nach Israel und zu unserem
Thema
[Applaus]
[Musik]
aufgepasst bisher haben wir die
Argumente derjenigen gehört die dass
Israel die Araber dazu verdammt unter
einem schrecklichen System der Apartheit
zu leiden aber lasst mich euch einfach
nur sagen dass es in dieser ganzen
Geschichte Dinge gibt die einfach
irgendwie nicht zusammenpassen und sie
passen auch dann nicht zusammen selbst
wenn es auf allen Seiten sicher viele
kritikwürdige und unschöne Dinge gibt
ich meine überlegt mal wenn es stimmen
würde dass die Araber eingekesselt und
eingemauert sind und vollständig von der
israelischen Regierung kontrolliert
werden wie ist es dann möglich dass die
kamamas stark genug war den Angriff am 7
Oktober überhaupt durchzuführen ich
meine das ist eine ganz einfache Frage
wenn Israel alle Grenzen streng
kontrolliert woher hatten sie dann das
riesige Arsenal an Waffen und drohen um
den Angriff auszuführen außerdem wie ist
es möglich dass die Hamas so viel Macht
in Gaza hat ja es gibt da Dinge die
einfach nicht zusammenpassen aber das
ist noch nicht das Ende der fanenstange
werf mal einen Blick auf diese Nachricht
israel hat am Mittwoch die Zahl der
Arbeitsgenehmigungen für Palästinenser
aus dem Westjordanland die in Israel
arbeiten wollen um 20.000 auf 120 000
erhöht es ist bekannt dass jeden Tag
10tausende Araber ohne israelischen Pass
nach Israel gefahren sind und dort
gearbeitet haben in diesem Zusammenhang
ist die Zahl der Araber die in Israel
Arbeiten den letzten Jahren ständig
gestiegen das passt wiederum ganz und
gar nicht zu der Theorie dass die
Israelis die Araber um jeden Preis in
einem freiluftgefängnis einsperren
wollten oder lass uns jetzt also die
erste Frage klären sind die Araber
wirklich in kleinen Gebieten eingesperrt
und dem Willen Israels
[Musik]
unterworfen um diese Frage zu
beantworten müssen wir uns zunächst über
eine Sache im Klaren sein die Araber im
westjöranland sind nicht dieselben wie
die im Gazastreifen und und gar nicht
wie jene mit israelischer
Staatsangehörigkeit seit 2005 ist der
Gazastreifen ein unabhängiges Gebiet in
diesem Gebiet hatte Israel bis zu
jüngsten Eskalation keine Truppen es
lebten dort auch keinerlei israelische
Bürger oder Juden alle jüdischen
Siedlungen jeglicher Art wurden 2005
entweder freiwillig oder gewaltsam
geräumt dabei war die Stadt Gaza
ursprünglich noch zur Römerzeit eine
jüdische Stadt und auch die folgenden
2000 Jahre dort weiterhin Juden wenn
auch Sie von muslimischen Zuwanderern
immer stärker verdrängt und 1929
schließlich vollständig bei einem prkrom
vertrieben wurden 133 von ihnen wurden
dabei ermordet und seit 2005 ist es
einzig und allein die radikal islamische
hamasorganisation die den Gazastreifen
kontrolliert und niemand sonst kurz
gesagt der Gazastreifen agiert im Grunde
wie ein unabhängiger Staat mit eigenen
Gesetzen eigener unabhängiger Politik
und eigener Armee israel hat in den
vergangenen Jahren dabei keinerlei Rolle
gespielt die aner haben innerhalb ihres
Landes alle Freiheiten undfreiheiten
Rechte und Pflichten die ihnen die
chamas ermöglicht oder auferlegt hat
Israel hat sich da überhaupt nicht
eingemischt natürlich kontrolliert
Israel seine Grenzen zum Gazastreifen
wie jedes andere normale Land auch mit
dem zusätzlichen Umstand dass seine
Zivilbevölkerung permanent durch
Terrorangriffe aus Gaza bedroht wird
quasi ein offener einseitig von Gaza
ausgehender Krieg herrscht und daher
sind logischerweise strengere
Grenzkontrollen erforderlich als
gegenüber einem friedlichen Staat aber
trotzdem nicht nur Israel hat eine
gemeinsame Grenze mit Gaza vergess dass
der Gazastreifen auch eine Grenze zu
Ägypten hat und zwar über den
Grenzübergang rafach und hier Verfahren
die Ägypter mindestens genauso streng
wie die Israelis natürlich gibt es
Einschränkungen für den Handel mit Gaza
aber es stimmt auch dass das Gebiet in
letzten Jahren dusussende Milliarden
Dollar an Entwicklungshilfe erhalten hat
und darüber hinaus von Israel mit Wasser
Strom Medikamenten und Lebensmitteln
versorgt wird und zwar umsonst es stimmt
auch nicht dass Gaza das am dichtesten
bevölkerte Gebiet der Welt sei das ist
eine weitere der vielen Propagandalügen
die hamasanhänger nicht müde werden
überall zu verbreiten die
bevölkerungssichte im Gazastreifen
beträgt 6500 Menschen pro
Quadratkilometer das entspricht etwa der
Hongkongs das ja auch 100 Jahre lang
eine isolierte Enklave am Meer war ohne
dass die Menschen dort wirtschaftlich
oder menschlich darben mussten zum
Vergleich die Bevölkerungsdichte von Tel
Aviv beträgt 8500 und die von Paris oder
Singapur gar 20.000 Menschen pro
Quadratkilometer können wir also davon
ausgehen dass Gaza ein freiluftgefängnis
sei oder es dort irgendeine Form von
Apartheit seitens Israel gebe nun
natürlich nicht ich weiß dass die lieben
Israelkritiker nicht müde werden diesen
Kampfbegriff gebetsmühlenartig zu
wiederholen und jeden damit zu
überschütten aber dadurch wird auch
diese Propagandalüge nicht wahrer auf
jeden Fall konnten wir bei Gaza bis zu
dem Zeitpunkt als sich Hamas entschloss
das größte Massaker an Juden seit dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg zu verüben von einem
de facto unabhängigen Stahl sprechen der
international zwar nicht anerkannt wird
ähnlich wie Transnistrien abhasien oder
sogar Taiwan dessen Einwohner aber nur
durch sich selbst unterdrückt werden
nicht durch irgendjemanden aus Israel
okay aber was ist mit dem Westjordanland
nun hier ist es noch viel
komplizierter wie wir bereits erwähnt
haben ist das Westjordanland seit 1993
grob in zwei Gebiete unterteilt auf der
einen Seite die Gebiete A und B in
diesen Gebieten leben 5% der Araber des
Westjordanlands sie haben ihre eigenen
Gesetze eigene Gerichte ihr eigenes
Gesundheitssystem ihr eigenes
Bildungswesen und eine eigene Regierung
die sogenannte Palästinensische
Autonomiebehörde die in gewisser Weise
wie die Regierung eines normalen Landes
handelt und hier können wir bereits eine
Sache erkennen und zwar dass die Araber
im Westjordanland in den Gebieten a& B
in der Tat anderen Gesetzen unterliegen
als die Israelis aber das liegt eben
daran dass sie unter ihren eigenen
Gesetzen leben die sie selbst abgesegnet
haben und sich somit selbst regieren in
diesem Zusammenhang wäre es
völkerrechtlicher Quatsch und natürlich
auch ziemlich unfair israelische Gesetze
auf die Araber des Westjordanlands ohne
israelische Staatsangehörigkeit
anzuwenden und ihn nicht zu erlauben
sich selbst zu regieren meint ihr nicht
und dennoch gibt es bei alldem eine
wichtige Nuance denn siee da es gibt im
Westjordanland auch noch die cgebiete
technisch gesehen sollten diese Gebiete
auch unter die Hoheit der
palästinensischen Autonomiebehörde
fallen allerdings wurde mit dem Oslo
Abkommen von 1993 festgelegt dass sie
vorübergehend unter der Kontrolle der
israelischen Regierung stehen und genau
hier entstehen viele der Probleme in den
cterritorien herrschen Militärgesetze
wenn ein palästinänsischer Araber ein
Verbrechen begeht wird er oder sie vor
ein Militärgericht gestellt und was ist
wenn es sich um ein Israeli handelt der
dort das Verbrechen
begeht
nun in diesem Fall wird der Israeli nach
dem Militärrecht und dem israelischen
Recht verurteilt das heißt nach beiden
gesetzsystemen zusammen allerdings kann
sich an Israeli dafür entscheiden von
einem Gericht in Israel verurteilt zu
werden was ein Vorteil sein könnte mit
anderen Worten in diesem Fall gibt es
eine klare rechtliche Unterscheidung
vulgo Diskriminierung und die Frage
lautet natürlich warum gibt es sie nun
laut Organisationen wie nesty
international aus rassistisch
diskriminatorischen Gründen aber
erinnert ihr euch doch um wen genau es
sich bei Amnesty international
eigentlich handelt genau es ist jene
Organisation die letztes Jahr nach dem
russischen Überfall auf die Ukraine
Putins Propagandalügen in aller Welt
verbreitete die Ukraine würde in Schulen
und Krankenhäusern Militärbasen aufbauen
und somit ihre eigene Zivilbevölkerung
als menschliche Schutzschilde
missbrauchen mehr noch selbst nachdem
sie im Rahmen einer internen
Untersuchung festgestellt hatte dass
dies einfach nicht zutrifft und selbst
als dieser interne Bericht an die
Öffentlichkeit geliegt wurde sah sie
sich nicht imstande sich zu
entschuldigen dadurch wurde klar dass
sowohl amnesty international als auch
andere sowohl nichtre ungs als auch
Regierungs und UN-Organisationen durch
Extremisten unterwandert sind die häufig
im Sinne von Diktatoren und tyranischen
Regimes agieren häufig dienen sie sich
ihnen aus ideologischen Gründen an aber
das ist ein Thema das wir in einem
separaten Video behandeln sollten kommen
wir lieber noch mal zum Westjordanland
zurück denn wie ist es überhaupt dazu
gekommen dass in den sogenannten
cterritorien Militärgesetze gelten ich
meine das ist ja wirklich kein
wünschenswerter Zustand nun das Problem
ist dass es sich um Gebiete handelt in
denen etwa 386 000 Israelis aber auch
300 1000 nicht israelische Araber Leben
und aus Sicherheitsgründen stehen sie
unter vorübergehender israelischer
Militärbesatzung der Punkt ist dass
Israel seine eigenen Gesetze an diesen
Orten nicht durchsetzen kann da dies als
politische Annexion aufgefasst werden
würde was in diesem Zusammenhang
international auf Ablehnung stoßen würde
das vielleicht größte Problem in dieser
ganzen Angelegenheit ist jedoch dass die
Besetzung der Zone C wie gesagt
vorübergehend und ausschließlich
militärisch sein sollte 1995 wurde im
Oslo 2 Abkommen zwar eigentlich
vereinbart dass das Gebiet schrittweise
in die Gerichtsbarkeit der
palästinensischen Autonomiebehörde
übergeben wird allerdings mit der Option
auf Landtausch im Rahmen eines
endgültigen Abkommens das Problem die PA
hat alle Vorschläge bezüglich eines
solchen endgültigen Abkommens immer
wieder abgelehnt und aus diesem Grund
sieht Israel keinen Anlass sich aus dem
Gebiet zurückzuziehen denn wie gesagt
Leben dort 386 000 israelische
Staatsbürger und natürlich besteht die
Sorge dass diese sonst von den Arabern
vollständig vertrieben werden so wie es
z.B in Gaza und den umliegenden
arabischen Ländern geschehen ist und um
das G ganze noch komplizierter zu machen
fördert Israel dort zudem seit fast vier
Jahrzehnten die zivile Ansiedlung
weiterer Israelis was den Konzept einer
ausschließlich militärischen Besetzung
ziemlich widerspricht Israel Siedlungen
haben keinen gültigen Rechtsstatus und
stellen einen eklatanten Verstoß gegen
das Völkerrecht da aber wie sieht es
angesichts dessen und abgesehen von der
möglichen rechtlichen Diskriminierung
von Arabern mit den
Bewegungseinschränkungen dort aus stimmt
es dass diese in kleinen Dörfern
eingesperrt sind ohne hinausgehen zu
können nun auch das ist eine stark
verbreitete propag
[Musik]
Lüge die Araber können sich im gesamten
Westjordanland allen drei Zonen frei
bewegen unabhängig davon ob sie einen
israelischen Pass haben oder nicht
richtig ist allerdings dass es viele
militärische Kontrollpunkte entlang der
Straßen gibt die endlose Staus und viele
wirtschaftliche Probleme verursachen
aber im Allgemeinen und selbst laut
propalästinensischen Organisationen wie
pelem beschränken sich die einzigen
Straßenabschnitte auf den Fahrzeuge mit
Kennzeichen der PA nicht fahren dürfen
auf etwa 40 km und das ist eben extrem
wenig wenn man bedenkt dass wir über ein
Straßennetz von mehr als 4700 km Länge
sprechen aber das Gebiet in das Araber
ohne israelischen Pass eindeutig nur
eingeschränkten Zugang haben ist
natürlich Israel selbst und auch die
Siedlungen in Zone C außer natürlich sie
haben eine gültige Arbeitserlaubnis und
die Frage ist natürlich warum ist ihr
Zugang eingeschränkt auch hier
argumentieren Organisationen wie Amnesty
dass es sich um Diskriminierung handeln
würde weil die sogenannten Palästinenser
als Bürger zweiter Klasse behandelt
würden um ein apartheitssystem durchzu
zen doch die von Israel vertretene
Theorie ist ganz anders laut Israel ist
es palästinensischen Arabern die also
keine Staatsbürger Israel selbst sind
aus Sicherheitsgründen verboten
israelisches Gebiet zu betreten es sei
denn Sie haben eben eine
Arbeitserlaubnis denn in dem Fall haben
sie ja einen backgroundcheck absolviert
s dass keine große Gefahr besteht dass
sie Anschläge begehen könnten und was
soll ich sagen angesichts dessen was wir
gesehen haben scheint es mehr als genug
Gründe dafür zu geben lieber vorsichtig
zu sein und dann gibt es noch etwas was
für die ganze Angelegenheit entscheidend
ist
die israelische Regierung schränkt nicht
nur die Einreise von Arabern ohne
israelischen Pass nach Israel ein Nein
für israelische Bürger ist die Einreise
in die von der PA kontrollierten Gebiete
genauso eingeschränkt sagen wir einfach
dass die Bewegungseinschränkungen in
Wirklichkeit sowohl auf der einen als
auch auf der anderen Seite liegen es
handelt sich eben um zwei Staaten die
ihre Grenzen kontrollieren und nicht
jeden reinlassen und in diesem
Zusammenhang war die PA sogar die erste
die diskriminierende Gesetze gegen Juden
erlassen hat wie z.B das Verbot Häuser
im Westjordanland zu kaufen abas wurde
jedem eine lebenslange Haftstrafe an der
Land an einen feindlichen Staat oder
einen seinen Untertanen abtritt
verpachtet oder verkauft im Grunde
handelt es sich dabei nur um ein
Beispiel innerhalb der langen traurigen
Tradition der Diskriminierung und
Vertreibung von Juden und Christen aus
allen Ländern und Regionen in denen die
Araber und Muslime nach und nach die
Macht an sich gerissen haben
Islamisierung verläuft in den meisten
Fällen eben total und totalitär und wie
gesagt Leben im Gegensatz dazu heute 2
Millionen Araber als vollwertige Bürger
im Staate Israel allein das zeigt die
großen zivilisatorischen Unterschiede
dieser beiden Kulturgruppen auf und es
zeigt eben auch dass man zwischen dem
System den Regeln und den Ausnahmen
unterscheiden muss und hier ist es
ziemlich eindeutig während die Juden
nämlich von Anfang an zusammen mit den
palästinensischen Arabern seit an seit
in Frieden zusammenleben wollen auch
wenn es Ausnahmen gibt ist es auf der
anderen Seite eben genau umgekehrt
allerdings gibt es auch dort viele
löbliche Ausnahmen und auf die kommen
wir noch zu sprechen aber trotzdem nach
allem was wir bisher gesehen haben
können wir ohne Zweifel sagen dass es im
Westjordanland keine Apartheit gibt nun
wenn wir es aus der Perspektive des
Konzepts V Staatsgrenzen betrachten
diese sind geschlossen für beide Seiten
und Israel kontrolliert das umliegende
Gebiet darüber hinaus sind die
Unterschiede zur eigentlichen Apartheit
allerdings sehr groß die
sicherheitsbedingten Regelungen Israels
bezüglich der nicht israelischen Araber
mit der brutalen Apartheit in Südafrika
zu vergleichen stellt eine unverfrorene
und im Grunde abgrundti rassistische
Verharmlosung des damaligen
unterdrückungsregimes der weißen
Bevölkerung gegenüber den schwarzen da
in Südafrika war die Apartheit
rassistisch motiviert und absolut die
schwarze Bevölkerung wurde menschlich
sie durfte keine weißen heiraten und
keine eigenen Unternehmen gründen mehr
noch sie durften doch nicht einmal
öffentliche Räume nutzen die nur für die
weißen reserviert waren eine
Gleichsetzung zwischen dem heutigen
Israel und dem damaligen Südafrika zeugt
entweder von einem vollkommen gestörten
geschichtsverhältnis oder von seinem
schamlosen rassistisch motivierten
Missbrauch was die Grenzen in
westjordderland angeht gibt es keinerlei
rassistisches Motiv für die Trennung
sondern ein staatsbürgerschaftliches und
ein sicherheitsmotiv das bedeutet dass
ein palästinensischer Bürger auch wenn
er kein Muslim ist unter den Regeln der
palästinensischen Autonomieregierung
lebt und auch ein israelischer
Staatsbürger selbst wenn er kein Jude
sonder ein Muslim ist lebt unter den
Regeln des israelischen Staates wie
jeder seiner Mitbürger auch aber
vielleicht fragt ihr euch ja wie es
eigentlich dazu gekommen ist dass heute
2 Millionen Araber als vollwertige
Staatsbürger in Israel leben nun das ist
im Grunde ganz einfach sie bzw ihre
Vorfahren haben sich in der Zeit als der
Staat Israel gegründet wurde nicht von
ihren politischen und religiösen Führern
dazu aufhätzen lassen die Juden
vertreiben zu wollen diese wollten
nämlich ursprünglich mit den arab AR
Zusammenleben und ihnen beim Aufbau
eines modernen Staatswesens einer guten
Infrastruktur und einer prosperierenden
Wirtschaft helfen ein Teil der Araber
ließ sich jedoch zum ewigen Hass gegen
die Juden aufstacheln während andere von
ihnen das gemeinschaftliche
Zusammenleben und eine Zukunft in
Frieden und Freiheit bevorzugten
letztere leben heute in Israel die
übrigen Irrlichtern als ewige
selbsternannte Opfer und Flüchtlinge in
der Weltgeschichte herum und zwar ohne
dass ein Ende ihrer ideologischen
amokfah die sie mittlerweile in viele
andere Länder der Region und der ganzen
Welt getragen haben absehbar wäre ohne
ihren ewigen Drang zur Feindschaft
könnte es Ihnen heute genauso gut gehen
wie allen Israelis aber kommen wir doch
noch mal auf jene arabischstämmigen
Israelis zurück falls ihr euch doch
erinnert haben wir zu Beginn dieses
Videos ja gesagt dass laut Organisation
wie Amnesty International Muslime sogar
in Israel selbst diskriminiert werden in
Ghettos eingesperrt und sogar in ihrem
Personalausweis gekennzeichnet sind
demnach gibt es also doch keinen Raum
für Zweifel wenn dem nämlich so ist
reden wir über die Diskriminierung von
vollwertigen israelischen Staatsbürgern
die möglicherweise aufgrund ihrer
Religion oder ethnischen Zugehör igkeit
schlechter behandelt werden die Frage
lautet also was ist an all dem dran
herrscht in Israel doch diese innere
aparthit nun genau das werden wir es
untersuchen
aufgepasst eine interne
[Musik]
apparteit eines ist hundertprozentig
sicher in Israel wurden die Menschen
viele Jahre lang nach ihrer ethnischen
Zugehörigkeit Unterschieden im
Personalausweis hatte jeder Bürger einen
volkszugehörigkeitsvermerk je nachdem ob
er Araber Jude oder einer anderen Ethnie
angehörte außerdem definiert sich der
Staat Israel als Nation der Juden was
uns der Annahme verleiten könnte dass es
eine negative Diskriminierung anderer
Ethnien gibt netanahu sagt israel sei
ein Nationalstaat des jüdischen Volkes
und nur dessen allein wohl gemerkt die
Juden sehen sich nicht nur als
Religionsgemeinschaft sondern auch als
Volk darüber hinaus gibt es muslimische
und jüdische Gettos religiöse Schulen
und selbst in Orten wie Ostjerusalem
gibt es unabhängige religiöse Räume die
Frage ist daher ist dies der ultimative
Beweis für Diskriminierung nun ja sehen
wir es uns doch lieber mal etwas genauer
[Musik]
an was den Personalausweis angeht so
wurde die Unterscheidung nach ethnischer
Zugehörigkeit im Jahr 2005 abgeschafft
und existiert seit 2015 überhaupt nicht
mehr doch selbst wenn es sie noch geäbe
wäre das nicht ungewöhnlich denn auch
Länder wie z.B die USA unterscheiden
verwaltungstechnisch zwischen Menschen
nach ihrer ethnischen Zugehörigkeit und
bieten in diesem Zusammenhang einige
Vorteile für Minderheiten an
US-Universitäten gibt es z.B Plätze die
nur für afroamerikanische Studierende
reserviert sind und auch in Israel haben
Nichtjuden einige Vorteile denn z.B sind
Muslime oder Christen nicht verpflichtet
in den Streitkräften zu dienen können
sich aber selbstverständig freiwillig
zum Wehrdienst melden sie werden also
keineswegs ausgeschlossen und was ist
mit den rein muslimischen Schulen oder
Gettos nun die Realität ist dass der
Besuch dieser Schulen rein freiwillig
ist es herrscht absolute Wahlfreiheit
und zwar für jeden wenn man Jude ist
wird man sein Kind am Esten in einer
Schule anmelden in der die jüdische
Religion unterrichtet wird Muslime
dagegen und denken wir daran dass
Muslime 20% der Bevölkerung Israels
ausmachen werden ihre Kinder natürlich
eher in eine muslimische Schule bringen
aber Sie müssen es nicht sie können es
genauso gut umgekehrt machen und
natürlich gibt es diese Fälle in Israel
auch das gleiche gilt dann auch für die
Ghettos wie in anderen Ländern auch
ziehen Mens mit ähnlicher Herkunft in
bestimmte Gebiete Orte wie little Cuba
in Miami Chinatown in London oder Little
Italy in New York
[Musik]
[Applaus]
entscheidend ist dass alle israelischen
Staatsbürger unabhängig von ihrer
Religion und etnie die gleichen
Bürgerrechte genießen das können wir in
der Politik selbst beobachten wo Zeh der
120 abgeordnet der kness Muslime sind
oder in der Justiz Israels wo Muslime
16% der Richter ausmachen oder sogar im
Militär selbst mit Soldaten wie diesen
hier ich fühle mich als Araber und
Muslim aber ich verstehe mich auch als
Teil dieses Landes Mahmut kashua
muslimischer IDF Soldat doch abgesehen
von der rechtlichen und zivilen
Gleichstellung ist es war dass Israel
bestimmte gesellschaftlich Gruppen mit
viel öffentlichem Geld begünstigt die
ultraorthodoxen Juden wären ein Beispiel
dafür aber auch wenn Israel sich selbst
als jüdische Nation bezeichnet hat der
Staat keine offizielle Staatsreligion
festgelegt so wie es viele islamische
Staaten tun und natürlich subventioniert
die Regierung auch muslimische Gemeinden
finanziell wenn auch in geringerem
Umfang und erlaubt selbstverständlich
die freie Ausübung aller Religionen 9
August 2023 der israelische
Ministerpräsident Benjamin Netanyahu hat
am Mittwoch zugesagt mindestens 54
Millionen US-Dollar für arabische Städte
bereitzustellen wenn man den stat Israel
für etwas kritisieren möchte dann dass
er die Religion an sich egal welche zu
sehr in bestimmte gesellschaftliche
Bereiche hineinfunken lässt ein Beispiel
ist hier das Familienrecht wo immer noch
religiöse Richter eingesetzt werden aber
jede Religion setzt hier eben ihre
eigenen Richter ein zusammenfassend
können wir also sagen dass Israel seine
Bürger nicht diskriminiert weil sie
Muslime oder Araber sind und dass die
Motive in der Grenzfrage eher mit der
Sicherheit der israelischen Bürger zu
tun haben als mit einem angeblichen
Versuch ein aparthit zu errichten oder
gar Völkermord zu begehen das alles sind
gefährliche Propagandalügen und
rassistisch hetzerische kampfbegriffe
die sofort scharf zurückgewiesen werden
müssen denn wie ihr gerade gesehen habt
gibt es für Sie keinerlei Grundlage das
soll natürlich nicht heißen dass man
Israel oder dessen Regierung nicht
kritisieren oder für ihre Fehler
verurteilen darf aber man muss dabei
fair und auf dem Boden der Tatsachen
bleiben Israel festigt schon seit
Jahrzehnten seine Vormachtstellung im
Westjordanland obwohl es genau weiß dass
es gemäß Oslo 2 die Gebiete eigentlich
irgendwann an die PA übergeben sollte
natürlich ist es eine Tatsache dass die
Führer der palästinensischen Araber auch
ihren Teil der Vereinbarung nicht
erfüllen sie sind nicht gewillt einer
endgültigen Lösung mit geeigneten
Gebietstausch zuzustimmen weil sie
einfach unfähig sind eine bitter
notwendige Kompromisslösung zu
akzeptieren und immer nur auf ihre
Maximalforderungen pochen und die
Israelis zementieren dann aus Trotz den
Status Quo immer weiter und siedeln mehr
und mehr Siedler an von denen einige
ziemlich militante Zeitgenossen sind
real verfolgt Israel dadurch eine
Politik die letzten Endes eher einer
expansionistischen Logik zu folgen
scheint als der Logik ein Ausweg aus dem
Konflikt zu suchen und seine
Verpflichtungen zu erfüllen darüber
hinaus ist Israel aber auch ein
demokratischer pluralistischer Staat in
dem Minderheiten verteidigt werden und
in dem es sehr weitreichende
Bürgerrechte gibt es ist das einzige in
der gesamten Region in dem jeder Bürger
eben auch die arabischen Rechte und
Freiheiten genießen die für uns im
besten selbstverständlich sind von denen
sich die Menschen in denen von Arabern
selbstverwalteten Staaten jedoch nur
träumen lassen können dies fängt beim
allgemeinen und freien Wahlrecht an
Israel ist der einzige Staat im Nahen
Osten in dem Araber das Recht haben an
wirklich pluralistischen Wahlen sowohl
als Wähler als auch als Kandidaten
teilzunehmen im Gazastreifen z.B der von
der Hamas kontrolliert wird gab es schon
seit vielen Jahren keine demokratischen
Wahlen nach international anerkannten
Standard Israel ist das einzige Land in
der Region in der Araber ihre Meinung
frei äußern und ihre Regierung
kritisieren können ist euch z.B
aufgefallen dass bei Interviews im
Gazastreifen nie auch nur ein schlechtes
Wort über die Hamas fallen darf das ist
natürlich kein Zufall Israel hingegen
hat eine lebhafte politische
Debattenkultur und eine aktive
Zivilgesellschaft arabische Bürger
können wie alle anderen ihre Meinung
frei äußern publizieren politische
Bewegung gründen und sich frei entfalten
besonders krass fallen die Unterschiede
bei Frauenrechten aus Frauen im westj
Land haben unter der prreierung zwar
grundsätzlich das Recht auf Bildung und
können sich beruflich betätigen aber
auch hier kann die soziale Realität
durch kulturelle und familiäre
Erwartungen geprägt sein die die
Möglichkeiten der Frauen einschränken im
Gazastreifen sind die Frauenrechte unter
der Herrschaft der chamas jedoch völlig
eingeschränkt konservative soziale
Normen und die shariaagesetze bestimmen
die Bewegungsfreiheit von Frauen und
ihre Möglichkeiten in Bildung und Beruf
und auch in vielen umliegenden
arabischen Ländern sieht es nicht viel
anders aus im Vergleich zu Ihnen ist
Israel einen Leuchtturm der Demokrat und
der Gleichberechtigung für alle geradezu
ein
antiapartheitstaat mehr Israel bedeutet
auch mehr Freiheit und mehr
Menschenrechte für Juden Araber Muslime
Christen und alle anderen weniger israel
steht hingegen für mehr Intoleranz
Korruption Tyrannei Entrechtung
Unterdrückung und Unfreiheit einfach für
mehr Apartheit aber was meint ihr was
sollte Israel eurer Meinung nach im
Westjordanland tun haltet ihr die
Apartheit Vorwürfe gegen Israel für
gerechtfertigt oder denkt ihr dass es
sich eher um einen rassistischen
Missbrauch dieses Begriffs handelt
sollte Israel mehr darauf achten seine
muslimischen christlichen und
atheistischen Bürger gegenüber gläubigen
Juden gleichzustellen schreibt uns eure
Meinung doch bitte in den
Kommentarbereich unter diesem Video denn
wie immer sind auf eure Diskussion und
eure Anregung zu diesem Thema schon
mächtig gespannt ich hoffe dass euch
dies Video gefallen hat und ihr
vielleicht auch etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns mit ein Like Teil mit
euren Freunden und diskutiert es auch
mit ihnen vergesst bitte auch nicht das
tolle Angebot unseres heutigen Sponsors
Bubble wahrzunehmen bis zu 70% Rabatt
falls ihr jetzt dem Link in der
Beschreibung oder dem Video folgt
natürlich freuen wir uns auch jederzeit
über eine Spende von euch mit uns dieses
Projekt weiterzuführen den Link dazu
findet ihr ebenfalls in der
Videobeschreibung mach's gut und bis
[Musik]
bald